the jurgen experience and i
one of my heroes albert camus great
french philosopher you know his point
about
living to the point of tears right and i
think what really
i find sad in this culture is cynicism
and hopelessness and it's like we're
blessed
you know we have this i mean there's
more beyond
the internet you can find people who are
making amazing things more opportunities
than you can count
and if you're just going to sit there
and mope i mean you're blowing this
great gift that
god's given you yeah well i think a lot
of those people that are moping
that are concentrating entirely on the
negative aspects of life they're doing
themselves a giant
service and they can't it's almost like
they can't help it i think there's a lot
of people that are affecting the way
culture
shifts today that are probably
clinically depressed
and one of the things i resent
enormously about culture
is this idea if something is joyous or
fun it's less
it's less legitimate artistically and
that is such a disgusting horrible
mindset and we need more joy and more
happiness
for me because i want to see jojo siwa
last night okay yeah
do you know who that is you don't know
who that is she's a youtube star
my nine-year-old loves her so i had a
it was how to go to jojo siwa's birthday
concert last night okay
at the microsoft center where the [ __ ]
that is i know because bert ran into her
at the airport loves her too
yeah i bet because bruh has young
daughters too yeah
um she's all about positivity yeah
believe and achieve
fun times i'll upload a video later but
is it also like is it all like
saccharine like disney stuff or is it
sincere
it's as sacred as it gets oh i don't
like that yeah yeah yeah
yeah like um yeah she was taking old
queen songs and reworking the words
cleaning them up oh she's like those
meme people oh she was she's cleaning
she's toning down queen songs tone down
some queen songs oh this woman's the
devil
how dare you take someone's art
and and appropriate it and make it like
uh
take out all the all the energy yeah she
this is corporate culture at its worst
but she's doing it for three-year-olds
bro
so just like five-year-olds they don't
need to be listening to queens
there it is oh jesus christ she loves
freddie mercury bro what's the problem
no she doesn't if she loved him she'd
respect him
oh she's [ __ ] 12 she know oh she's 16
excuse me
yeah she didn't know any better she does
know better how smart were you when you
were 16. smart enough not to try to
rewrite queen
i bet she doesn't have a saying it i bet
whoever's pulling the strings
gets her to read that makes it even more
nefarious of course the disney people
are the
the the sensors whatever it is the
producers wait
am i wrong where's the lie where's the
lie
what song was it that they did it too
too i'm trying to remember they did we
are the champions
she sang that
but champions i mean someone's a loser
yeah no time for losers so was it what
was that change to no time no no no i
don't think they
changed that no time for recess
[Laughter]
oh my god this is horrifying yes this is
like those videos
this is like those videos they made for
like mormons where they took like
hollywood blockbusters and
cut out all the sex and all the cursing
yeah and it's like you are
evil vampires horrible monsters she did
crocodile rock elton john
okay and she changed rainbow chevy to
rainbow beamer
so crocodile rock you know my theories
of that song i tweeted this out years
ago
what i just imagined elton with a bunch
of his friends all getting high as [ __ ]
right and they're like all right let's
try to think of the most [ __ ] up lyric
and eric elton you're gonna make a song
about it they're like how about like um
like crocodile rock and he's like all
right i'll [ __ ] do it
he [ __ ] sits and nails it